[Musique]
bonjour Didier kibel bonjour Patrice je
ne serai jamais loin de toi c'est le
titre de votre deuxè roman hein tout à
fait oui euh vous étiez déjà venu pour
le premier qui s'appelait les Rouses
bleu il y a un lien très très fort entre
les les deux livres même si on peut lire
celui-là sans avoir lu le premier oui
oui l'idée effectivement c'était de à la
fois s'inscrire dans une suite mais
effectivement de d'écrire le le roman de
façon suffisamment à droite pour qu'on
puisse le lire sans avoir lu le premier
mais avec l'espoir bien sûr pas du tout
contenu que en ayant lu le second le
deuxème on ait envie de de lire le
premier bien sûr euh on on parler
quelques mots de vous vous êtes
versaillais hein oui bien sûr euh et
vous avez habité euh pendant toute votre
enfance euh au au théâtre montancier
quoi enfin pas dans le théâtre mais dans
l' immeuble qui est dans le où il y a le
théâtre dans le théâtre montancier
effectivement puisque dans le théâtre il
y a effectivement bah le l'aspect salle
de spectacle bien entendu mais il y
avait aussi tout un tas de de
d'appartement en fait c'était des pièces
dont dont certaines ont été transformées
en appartement et j'avais effectivement
cette chance d'habiter dans le théâtre
et donc dès mon plus jeune âge j'ai pu
euh aller voir écouter euh les pièces de
théâtre et euh minicié finalement aux
classi et le plus facile c'est
effectivement Molière de rentrer dans
Molière c'est quand même assez facile
nous a donné le leû de la littérature
vous dites he oui sans sans aucun doute
c'est c'est Molière qui m'a donné cet
amour des mots de de la littérature et
puis l'envie de lire aussi
puisque dans dans dans ma jeunesse il y
avait Mme un peu moins d'activité
qu'aujourd'hui électronique notamment
formatique donc on lisait on lisait
beaucoup et vous dites une chose qui est
assez intéressante euh au fond il y
avait il y a les soirs de représentation
et puis les autres et il y a pas du tout
évidemment la même ambiance dans les
couliss si je peux dire du théâtre et
c'était très très très très
impressionnant pour moi parce Queen fait
cette salle de de spectacle quand elle
était vide et j'avais la chance de
pouvoir y accéder en fait elle était
elle était éteinte elle était sombre il
se passait rien et et bon petite
anecdote un peu bête mais c'était aussi
l'époque où je sais pas si vous souvenez
il y avait une une série télévisée qui
s'appelleit bféor sûr et
belféor assez terrorisant quand on était
un gamin et moi j'étais dans un décor un
petit peu
semblable Ann 60 fin des années 60 voilà
ou oui un peu plus 65 6 là voilà voilà
ah oui vous étiez gamin ah oui oui
j'étais vraiment gamin oui ça faisait
peur très très donc la littérature je
l'ai aimé grâce à ça et puis après comme
j'avais le théâtre comme vous le savez
donne sur le bassin de Neptune donc donc
les jardins du château de versaill
j'avais la chance d'y accéder aussi
quand je voulais et donc ça m'a donné à
la fois l'amour de la nature l'amour de
de l'architecture de l'art en général
voilà vous avez jamais pensé écrire pour
le théâtre non pour l'instant non pour
l'instant non peut-être un jour
mais peu t
et et alors après vous avez fait tout à
fait autre chose vous êtes devenu
ingénieur oui oui avant j'ai fait enfin
pendant les études j'ai étais pigiste
dans dans des journaux régionaux
notamment et puis après j'ai eu à
choisir en me disant est-ce que je
prends une puis j'avais la possibilité
de devenir journaliste oui ou est-ce que
je continue donc j'ai continué mes
études puis j'ai fait un parcours
d'ingénieur avec un petit regret quand
même quelque part mais bon voilà donc
j'ai j'ai continué à écrire des petites
choses dans mon coin des petits billets
d'humeur des que je gardais
précieusement et puis assez récemment
finalement j'ai oui parce que vous êtes
un un un un jeune écrivain un un nouvel
auteur comme
je j'imerais bien mais assez récemment
donc je me suis dit est-ce que je suis
Chable finalement d'écrire un roman dans
son intégralité d'aller jusqu'au bout
voilà comment ça par que vous aviez
commencé des petits bouts non oui oui
des petits bouts oui tout à fait oui des
petits bout même un livre assez bien
construit élaboré mais je je l'ai laissé
dans un tiroir vous les regarder de
temps en temps les petits bout pour vous
donner des des idées non j'en ai
conservé j'ai pas tout conservé mais
j'en ai quelquesuns ou effectivement des
petits bouts que regard que je relis et
qui parfois peuvent m'inspirer
d'ailleurs h je dis vous êtes ingénieur
c'est un peu comme l'un de vos héros
Marc he qui est oui oui oui oui oui tout
à fait ah oui oui alors Marc dans dans
ce roman c'est un un ingénieur
spécialiste de neurosciences il s'est
spécialisé là-dedans il a fait des
recherches qui ont été marqué marquantes
et qui font référence voilà alors dans
le le premier roman qui s'appelait les
roses bleues oui euh bah
c'était l'amour enfin la rencontre entre
Marc et Diane euh même si on y reviendra
parce que c'est une question qui qui hon
aussi le 2è livre Marc a eu deux amours
Diane et Nadia oui euh mais là euh voilà
il eu cet amour pendant dans le premier
roman Les Roses bleu entre entre Marc et
Diane et là on on commence ENF ça
s'ouvre la scène d'ouverture on est sur
la dune du Pila hein ce qui est un
endroit que vous aimez beaucoup je
oui oui oui tout à fait et puis c'est
c'est l'endroit où où Dian et Mar se
sont aimés et là c'est plus tragique
puisque euh bah on va euh répondre les
les cendres de Diane est morte VO oui
oui
oui effectivement alors ce roman donc je
je je je le dis il s'inscrit dans dans
la littérature blanche hein au sens où
je crois que je vous l'avais dit à la
première émissioni j'aime pas entendre
sans arrêt des mauvaises nouvelles de la
violencef enfin tout tout ce dont les
hommes finalement sont capables de faire
l'actualité nous montre de quoi on est
capable donc moi j'ai voulu délibérément
inscrire des choses qui soi plus
romantique
sentimental s on va parler de la
mor savoir si la mort existe vraiment
mais euh voilà donc enfin Dian Dian
Diane est morte et on répond puisque
c'est là qui sont aé al là il y a il y a
il y a Marc donc qui était qui était son
son l'homme de sa vie ils se sont aimés
passionnément pendant 7 an même si même
s'il a eu un autre amour même si moment
ça s arrêté Kevin qui est le fils de
Dian absolument et et et la fille et
leur qui est la fille de Nadia c'est ça
oui Laura tu es la fille de Marc de Marc
oui oui etevin qui est la fille le fils
le
fil voilà en fait ils ont eu
effectivement chacun un en enfant
séparément c'est ça voilà et donc bon
ils sont là et donc voilà les cendres il
répondent les cendres et là euh c'est
leura qui qui trouve un petit une petite
cassette comme ça
euh le met dans son sac à dos en se
disant en fait personne n fait attention
sauf elle hein d'ailleurs non non pas
vraiment effectivement puisque
effectivement c'est au moment où ils
vont après avoir répandu les cendres
disperser descendre ils vont décider de
d'enterrer l'urne cinéraire et c'est là
que en creusant dans la dune ils vont
rencontrer ce petit objet qui va être
rejeté par Marc parce que ça va ça va le
déranger effectivement à ce moment-là et
qui va être ramassé par par Laura de
façon assez instinctive voilà d'accord
et puis bah un jour comme ça on finit
par ouvrir cette cette cassette et on
trouve une une gourmette et une lettre
absolument oui et et Mar se dit qu
est-ce qui a pu écrire cette lettre à
qui ça appartient il fait des recherches
oui et et il trouve que c'est un certain
Fernand hein c'est ça qui a écrit qui a
écrit cette lettre qui appartienit cette
gourmette et Fernand est mort euh il a
été il y a une scène qui qui nous ramène
dans les années de guerre en 43 où il
essaie d'échapper au STO euh et puis
donc Marc va chercher à
qui à qui peut donner cette cette lettre
et alors il trouve le fils de de Fernand
c'est ça hein oui Henri oui absolument
et puis et puis la la femme de de de
Fernan qui s'appelle rose qui vit dans
un
épade effectivement ouioui tout à fait
et et voilà alors là on a on a le début
du livre
après je sais pas jusqu'où on peut aller
après bah après ce ce qu'on peut
peut-être dire effectivement c'est que
c'est c'est un roman
qui à la fois
propose on va dire un voyage temporel
comme vous l'avez dit on remonte aux
années 42 l'occupation allemande du
bassin
d'Arcachon jusqu'à la période
contemporaine
actuel c'est un voyage aussi
géographique parce qu' on va le voir ça
commence effectivement sur le basson
Arcachon ça
va juste en Inde et puis on va voir
qu'il y a aussi des petits passages en
Provence vers Trouville d'ville et
cetera voilà et et puis la dernière
chose si vous permettez Patrice c'est
que c'est aussi un voyage que j'appelle
spiritu au sens où
effectivement on va avoir des choses qui
vont se passer au niveau du mental au
niveau de de la recherche
voilà on peut dire quand même dans cette
lettre qui a retrouvver de de ce Fernand
qui est
mort il il sait qu'il va mourir en fait
et au gros bah c'est c'est lui qui dit à
Rose sa femme je ne serai jamais loin de
toi en fait en gros c'est ça hein
est-ce que est-ce que je vais vraiment
mourir d'ailleurs est-ce que je
reviendrai d'une d'une autre façon c'est
c'est l'énigme qu' laisse dans dans un
peu dans dans cette lettre et vous allez
trouver cette Rouse dans dans un ép vous
avez été très marqué par le covid ou pas
par beaucoup page sur les des gestes
barrières les masques non je je P non
j'en ai pas mis trop j'ai juste voulu
dire à un moment comme comme cette dame
est très âgée en ÉPA il fallait prendre
une petite précautions des précautions
sanitaires pour pouvoir discuter avec
elle sans remettre en en cause sa vie
non non j'ai pas été spécialement marqué
simplement c'est un épisode qui nous a
tous touché donc donc voilà pour ça m'a
amusé euh on peut quand même sans sans
tout dévoiler oui bien sû euh dire
que il y a des coïncidences oui entre
entre ce ce ce Fernan qui est mort et et
Dian dont on a dispè les SRES absolument
euh quand h effectiv pas quand Henri
quand quand Fernand est décédé donc
celui qui avait enterré la
petite voilà c'est la même année à
quelqu aès que la naissance de Dian et
puis il y a effectivement pas mal de
d'autres coïncidences d'autres hasards
qui vont
effectivement Marc avait offert des
roses bleues qui étaient les les fleurs
les
Rouses il se trouve que la veuve de de
Ferd s'appelle rose oui oui oui il y a
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui qui
coincide et qui encore une fois vont
jeter le trouble vont perturber
considérablement même l'esprit d'un d'un
scientifique comme
comme riste
VO voilà est-ce que vous croyez comme
disait au force de
l'esprit mais effectivement euh qu quand
je me suis lancé dans dans dans
l'écriture de ce roman au départ j'étais
un peu jubitatif
voir pas du tout convaincu et et quand
on regarde un peu tous les témoignages
qui existent qui sont assez concordants
et qui sont des milliers de témoignages
on on peut effectivement se poser des
questions s'interroger sur la qui sur
quoi sur la réincarnation sur le bah euh
notamment oui est-ce qu'on vraiment
est-ce que vraiment la mort physique euh
est un point d'arrêt définitif ou est-ce
que on peut imaginer qu'il se passe
d'autres choses au niveau de l'esprit de
l'âme de l'être enfin peu importe
comment on l'appelle mais mais
effectivement il y a des choses qui sont
un peu étonnante et qui font que bah ce
scientifique là il va il va vraiment
gratter la question il va rencontrer des
gens il va lire il y a beaucoup de
choses dans dans les religions sur ces
questions il va rencontrer des gens y
compris en Provence il va aller voir un
médium et puis finalement il va aller en
Inde il va aller en Inde alors faut que
vous me parliez d'une plante qui
s'appelle la datura oui le datura le
datura c'est une une plante
effectivement qui est qui est sa dans
dans dans plusieurs pays il y a des des
des plantes qui sont capables et porter
effectivement d'apporter des effets au
moins
hallucinatoiresouou des psychotrop VO
voir beaucoup plus grave plus grave qui
peuvent entraîner la mort si le dosage
n'est pas
fait il faut quoi voilà et donc
effectivement bah le le datura c'est
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose que Marc
va expérimenter ça me revage alors il y
a des gens qui vont prendre d'autres
types de drog oui oui ça va le secouer
ça le secouer hein et voilà vous avez
pris déjà non non bien sûr que non non
vous êtes vous êtes documenté là-dessus
non oui beaucoup oui oui beaucoup mais
c'est ça qui est intéressant quand on
est auteur romancier en plus aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'accès quand
j'étais gamin encore une fois j'allais à
la bibliothèque à Montberon vous êtes
allé en Inde ou c'est même pas là oui
oui je suis allé en Inde bien sûr je
suis allé en Inde oui oui voilà et et
donc c'est c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'accès et puis on peut effectivement
euh euh bien travailler les sujets parce
que moi ce que je tiens je sais pas vous
avez dû le remarquer dans dans mes
romans je tiens à mettre des choses
vérifiées avérées qui soit pas des des
des choses sur ce que je mets sur la
deème guerre mondiale c'est des choses
effectivement qui sont euh des élment
historique injecté dans un roman il y a
il y a un chapitre qui s'appelleit si
c'était vrai oui et et alors ça me fait
penser c'est Marc Levi et bien sûr bien
sûr alors je me suis voilà est-ce que
est-ce que di kimel est pas plus plus
impressionné par Marc Levi par Molière
finalement non non je vous l'avais dit
mais si c'était vrai ça c'était aussi
dans dans un roman de Marc Levy où bah
on s'interroger sur la la réalité de la
mort mais vous avez fait exprès je
supposeou j'ai fait exprès naturellement
monsieur Mar l je vous l'ai dit Virg
Grimaldi enfin des gens comme ça moi
j'aime bien ce type de de littérature ce
qu'on appelle les f good books oui oui
oui oui c'est ça oui oui tout à fait ou
c'estd que voilà les les choses peuvent
même les plus dramatiques peuvent
peuvent avoir un bon côté en tout cas je
dis pas je dis pas qu'rang un petit peu
un peu d'espoir parce que on va pas
aboutir à à une conclusion enfin si on
peut le faire mais qui tu dirait bah
voilà tout est foutu c'est terrible
concernant alors moi dans mes roman ce
j'aime bien aussi c'est vous l'avez vu
d'abord c'est donné la parole de façon
importante au personnages il y a
beaucoup de dialogue et puis aussi
mener des histoires en parallèle vous
l'avez dit il y a cette histoire là il y
a aussi une histoire on va dire
sentimentale par ailleurs absolument
alors il y a deux thèmes sur lesquels
vous que vous avvez abordé dans le
premier sur lesquels vous revenez il y a
les roses bleu oui oui oui bien s parce
que c'est voilà c'est en effet une
énigme c'est rose bleue qu'on trouve à
bordeau notamment en trouve ou oui on
trouve ailleurs et puis il y a il y a
cette question c'est est-ce qu'on peut
aimer deux personnes à la fois deux
femmes à la fois puisque là il s'agit de
de femmes pour Marc euh c'est une
question qui voilà vous l'aviez posé
beaucoup dans puisque c'était le
sous-titre du premier roman estce que
l'amour peut se conjuguer au pluriel est
qu'imé peut se conjuguer au pluriel et
et là alors là c'est la fille de c'est
la fille de Marc qui lui dit mais
explique-moi quoi alors il y a une
petite erreur je je allez-y pe c'est
page 77 euh oui j'ai j'ai besoin d'une
précision est-ce que tu as aimé
sincèrement Diane et Laura or non c'est
Diane et Nadia c'est Diane et Nadia et
dans les tirages qui ont été refaits la
l'erreur a été corrigée effectivgé et
malgré tout le soin qu'on apporte vous
savez bien il est resté effectivement
quelques coquill oui oui voilà dans
celle-ci très désagréable mais
effectivement mais bon ça été corrigé
oui par que c'est oui oui bien sûr bien
sûr Nadia et puis que c'est Laura c'est
la filleille c'est la
fille effectivement Laura revient sur
cette question parce que elle veut
absolument comprendre comprendre
pourquoi son père
c'est aventuré entre guillemets dans
dans une histoire pareille et c'est vrai
que c'est difficile à comprendre pour
pour pour notre culture notre
civilisation nos croyances qu'on puisse
être amoureux mais vraiment amoureux de
de deux personne à la fois donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle
elle le triture un petit peu pour que il
puisse apporter des explications mais
c'est un des thèmes qui vous qui qui est
assez fort chez vous quoi oui oui parce
que c'est c'est c'est intéressant comme
sujet donc voilà pourquoi c'est
développé mais on voit bien que que Marc
a beaucoup de mal à expliquer
précisément ce qui se passe quoi dans sa
tête pass alors voilà on va pas aller
plus loin mais mais en effet c'est d' un
questionnement sur bah sur sur la vie
sur la mort si je peux dire oui oui
c'est plus ça c'est c'est finalement
est-ce
que une fois que qu'on décède est-ce que
vraiment il se passe rien ou est-ce que
on est tous confrontés à un moment de
notre vie à des à des choses qui nous
semblent
étrangesriencesém vous saz de
décorporation la lumière blanche des
choses comme ça il y a des milliers de
témoignages comme ça alors vous êtes
vous vous ça ça ça je veux dire est-ce
que ça aide de penser qu'il y a
peut-être quelque chose est-ce que ça
aide à affronter justement ce ce ce
moment dont on sait qu'il un jour ça ça
aide si on y croit il y a des gens qui y
croient naturellement maintenant il faut
en être persuadé moi moi c'est ça
j'essaie de de de montrer toutes C
question toutes ces interrogations qu'on
peut avoir et puis finalement t toutes
ces absences de certitude parce que
finalement personne n'est capable de
dire scientifiquement et définitivement
une fois que vous êtes décédé il y a
plus rien après personne encore une fois
n'est revenu pour si ce n'est ces
expériences 2 vous savez de de mort
imminente dont on a des témoignages mais
qui bien sûr son sujet et qui sont c'est
c'est très intéressant parce qu'ils sont
très semblables T c
t voil alors donc on voit sa vie on est
dans un tunnel et ceter voilà mais vous
savez bon on on a bien sûr pas pas le
temps mais mais il il y a beaucoup de
d'expérience et de de de de de
scientifiques de neuroscientifiques qui
se sont penchés sur cette question et
qui essaient d'expliquer finalement que
il y a peut-être des explications plus
plus rationnelles entre la la la survie
entre guillemets du du cerveau par
rapport à celle du cœur qui reste encore
quelqu qui expliquerait que voilà av
même pesé l'â aussi voilà voilà voilà le
poid de l'âme mais mais en fait c'est
tellement mais c'est tellement
passionnant comme sujet quand on on
gratte un peu les choses que je suis en
train de d'écrire un 3ème roman et ce 3è
roman donc j'ai dis comme ça ça fera une
trilogie et puis on arrêtera là sur ce
sujet après où où là Marc il va se
retrouver
embarqué dans une étude scientifique où
on va essayer de justement d'apporter
une bution pour dire est-ce que oui ou
non l'âme l'esprit peu importe existe
voilà alors donc c'est c'est un
challenge un peu compliqué dans lequel
je me suis lancé parce que pas facile de
d'apporter une démonstration ou une
contribution mais c'est passionnant
passionnant voilà je ne serai jamais
loin de toi c'est aux éditions Le list
bleu comme les roses comme les roses
alors il nous reste quelques minutes
parce que je voudrait qu'on
parle vous avez été à la suite de de
l'pparition de votre premier roman
invité aux États-Unis hein oui au
festival du livre
de d'un réseau qui s'appelle rencontre
des auteurs francophone c'est ça voilà
et et comment s'appelle la alors la
fondatrice s'appelle Sandrine meres
cucurusce voilà qui était qu'on avait on
avait dé faitit émission voilà tout à
fait une émission précédente et donc
elle réunit des auteurs francophones
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est une
journaliste qui a fait beaucoup
d'événements euh importants euh sur les
États-Unis et qui effectivement a créé
un réseau qui regroupe un peu près 350
auteurs francophone donc du du monde
entier mais tous franement français mais
mais qui écrivent tous en français tous
en français et alors en en plus de cette
réunion euh elle a lancé donc une maison
d'édition c'est ça elle a lancé alors
elle a elle a lancé le réseau en 2020
justement à l'époque du covid voyez et
puis ce réseau donc s amplifié beaucoup
de d'auteurs célèbrent ou pas d'ailleurs
on rejoint le réseau le parrain c'est
Marc Levi
justement voà et et la marine c'est
Amanda d'accord
voilà et donc en juin récemment elle a
créé une maison d'édition voilà et les
deux premiers titres alors en fait c'est
alors il y a déjà trois titres deux
titres qui sont parus un troisième qui
va l'être dans dans peu de temps vous
avez la chance de l'irà l'homage au
Petit Prince d'abord lui il est paru
hein alors l'omage prince c'est
effectivement pour célébrer l'apparition
du Petit Prince d'Antoine de
saint-zupéri elle a réuni 80 hauteurs
pour écrire 80 ou ou poèmes ou nouvelles
et cetera oui oui bien sûr parce que
vous êtes un un un amoureux de saint
exupérri et du Petit Prince ah oui du
Petit Prince en particulier c'est ma
lecture de chevet depuis que je sais
lire et je l'ai lu à plusieurs reprises
et on en tire toujours des choses
puissantes oui oui oui très bien ch et
puis il y a apparaître alors vous nous
l'z apporté mais il est pas encore c'est
formableandrine voilà un hommage à
Albert Camu oui créé c'est vivres deux
fois voilà c'est pour les 120 ans de de
la naissance d'Albert Camu là encore là
il y a un peu moins lui aussi demandé si
on pouvait amer deux personnes à la
fois paril une Lison très très très très
forte avec une grande actrice et et et
donc là cette fois si on est que 40
auteurs il y a que 40 auteurs qui ont
contribué vous écrit aussi oui oui oui
bien sûr j'ai écrit aussi sur quoi alors
sur effectivement alors pareil au départ
une histoire d'une rencontre entre un
homme et une femme et puis une femme qui
qui qui est prof prof d'histoire à la
Sorbonne et qui va rencontrer un
monsieur il vont discuter et puis ils
vont arriver finalement sur c'est quoi
c'est quoi vos passions et puis ah benah
c'est c'est la lecture et c'est quoi
comme lesurf et cetera des questions un
petit peu on va dire classiques au début
d'une relation et puis rapidement ils
vont s'orienter sur Al Albert ah oui
donc c'est une fiction oui oui c'est
complètement une fiction là dedans il y
a c'est plutôt des fictions oui enfin
moi ou oui oui oui oui tout à fait alors
et donc ça s'appelle donc homage à
Albert Camu et les éditions s'appellent
ah bah c'est l'édition c'est rencontre
des auteurs francophones tout
simplement et on retrouve ça alors bien
sûr c'est diffusé très largement aux
États-Unis sur Amazon et cetera voilà
ben alors sandrine est très très active
elle a bien sûr créé cette maison elle a
créé des antennes maintenant il y a
plusieurs antennes dans plusieurs pays
du monde euh elle a un blog elle a café
littéraire elle a une chaîne Youtube
enfin c'est vraiment débordant et puis
des festivals et d'ailleurs je suis à
nouveau j'ai la chance l'honneur et
l'avantage d' à nouveau invité sur New
York et Washington au mois de mai pour
présenter vous rencontrez quoi des des
des des des Français qui vivent aux
États-Unis souventf francopones
essentiellement des des des Français qui
vivent aux États-Unis p bien s et puis
des g francopones voilà c'est tout à
fait intéressant et donc vous avez des
lecteurs aux
ÉtatsUnis trs bien merci beaucoup
did je rappelle le titre du de votre
dernier roman enfin 2è pas dernier un
trè dernier qui apparu qui s'appelle je
ne serai jamais loin de toi merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui vous remercie
bonne
journée
[Musique]